ja der gaststättenbetreiber der spürt
instinktiv dass es im dezember eben noch
nichts wird mit wieder aufmachen von
seinem restaurant und seiner kneipe der
wird es halt gerne von ihnen dann
irgendwann hören der mann wird muss
jetzt noch eine woche warten erfährt der
jetzt kann er den namen wir es an warten
wir es ab warten wir's ab kann er denn
damit rechnen dass dann wieder
finanziell aufgefangen wird dass die
staatshilfen verlängert werden ja ganz
klar
wenn einrichtungen geschlossen bleiben
dann haben wir uns ja komitee dass der
staat helfen muss und das muss auch so
bleiben also das ist ganz klar
es würde ja keinen sinn machen wenn wir
sagen jetzt sind vier wochen zu nannte
neben der mann es wird um fünf tage
verlängert dann würde es keine hilfe
geben
das geht für meine corona hilfe und es
geht auch um den fairen ausgleich für
die belastung da muss dann der staat
entsprechend einspringen
im übrigen muss man eines sagen auch bei
der gastronomie ich glaube schon dass
gerade die konzepte die getätigt wurden
in hochwertigen speiselokalen
beispielsweise dass da eine menge von
dem was da schon auf den weg gebracht
wurde auch helfen kann schneller dann am
ende wieder in ein normales gastronomie
leben zu finden aber es gibt halt nach
wie vor sehr viele kleinere zum beispiel
schankwirtschaften da stellt sich die
lage deutlich schwieriger da und auch
von der hygiene her weniger belastbar
als beispielsweise in entsprechenden
speiselokalen die man kennt das heißt es
ist ein wort das sie diesen wirken geben
jetzt über nicht nur november hinaus
sondern ebenso lange wie ihr geschäft
geschlossen bleibt wegen corona lockt
tanz ich werde mich dafür einsetzen als
teil der bundesregierung ja